the amount of data available to
businesses has created incredible demand
for people who know how to make good use
of data to support decision making
businesses are also generating more and
more data internally as they take
advantage of new technologies all this
data can be used to help come up with
solutions to a host of questions
[Music]
many people we come across leave unique
data scientists or programmers to answer
these types of questions the great news
is that you don't need to rely on others
to solve your data related problems but
in fact you can solve majority of
business problems with the most commonly
used predictive methodologies by
yourself and more importantly when you
need it all without programming the
business analyst nanodegree will give
you the skills you need to prepare a
data set build predictive models and use
the results to solve business problems
come join us and take your skills to the
next level
you